oui au sud est de la région celle de
mâcon et cluny notamment le député
sortant c'est l'ancien socialiste thomas
thévenoud qui a décidé de se retirer de
la vie politique dans cette
circonscription au premier tour de la
présidentielle les électeurs ont placé
emmanuel macron en tête suivi de
françois fillon puis marine le pen
jean-luc mélenchon et benoît hamon alors
pour succéder à thomas thévenoud le ps a
choisi catherine ndiaye conseillère
municipale de mâcon mais la gauche est
divisée
à droite aussi d'ailleurs gabrielle
talon quant à césar
la première circonscription de saône et
loire compte un peu plus de 100000
habitants dont plus de la moitié réside
dans l'agglomération mâconnaise
elle s'étend du canton de saint gengoux
le national au nord à celui de la
chapelle de gâcher au sud en passant
dans le clunysois en 2012 c'est thomas
thévenoud qu'il emporte dans ses tirs
conditions pourtant traditionnellement à
droite mais son rêve se transforme en
cauchemar
et il quitte la politique un boulevard
qui s'offre à l'heure à la droite jean
patrick courtois part favori mais il
doit faire face à une candidature
dissidente celle de son éternel rival
gérard voisin pour le maire de mâcon
cette élection c'est l'occasion de
retrouver le parlement après
l'invalidation de son élection comme
sénateur en 2015 les électeurs me
connaissent je suis élu de cette
circonscription les gens ont vu comment
j'ai transformé mâcon ont vu comment
j'ai transformé la petite commune
dompierre les ormes lorsque j'étais
maire j'étais conseiller général rural
ils s'en souviennent
aujourd'hui je suis présent de la
communauté d'agglomération il voit
l'évolution de l'agglomération et je le
redis ce que j'ai fait au plus fort de
moi-même pour développer cette
agglomération des jeux le donnait à la
première circonscription
c'est dans le garage familial que se
trouve le local de campagne de gérard
voisin
là où tout a commencé et il dira à 71
ans celui qui a été 20 ans député et 31
ans maire de charnay les mâcon brigue un
nouveau mandat
loin du renouvellement dans les buts ans
le renouveau je détestais les électrices
et les électeurs de cette
circonscription contestée y compris les
électeurs socialistes
du moment avec un renouveau avant
l'heure puisque j'étais opposé à
à thomas thévenoud et on a vu ce que ça
a donné le renouveau cette première
circonscription de saône et loire est la
seule du département où emmanuel macron
est arrivé en tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle pour l'élection
législative la république en marche
investi un jeune entrepreneur
à 38 ans bazana dire qu'il est à la tête
d'une entreprise de formation
c'est la première fois qu'il se présente
à une élection je pense que la politique
n'est pas un métier
on se met on s'engage c'est pas évident
de s'engager quand on vient de la
société civile c'est au delà des efforts
c'est qu'on sait très bien que les
problématiques que ça peut engendrer
pour un chef d'entreprise on peut
l'imaginer quand il reviendra après dans
le monde dans le monde privé si je le
fais c'est parce que je pense que
aujourd'hui on est en train de décider
de l'avenir de la france pour les 30
prochaines années dans les rues de
cormatin séance de tractage pour nico de
caboche
la candidate du front national espère
parvenir au second tour malgré deux
handicaps la candidature concurrente
d'une ancienne membre de son parti et le
fait de ne pas résider dans la
circonscription
ça ne s'est pas parachutée alors
répliqué je ne suis pas parachutée dans
ce léger ensuite je suis né en saône et
loire
ma famille est originaire de cette
circonscription entre autres trevi et
verosvres j'ai de la famille sur mâcon
donc je ne suis pas du tout parachute et
mais vous résidez à mons mais je réside
à montceau-les-mines de ce ça s'est fait
comme ça
à mâcon la france a soumises avait créé
la surprise en arrivant deuxième du
premier tour de la présidentielle sur la
place saint-pierre patricia bas s'ils
tentent de maintenir cet élan malgré une
candidature communiste face à l
inscription
les candidats qui peuvent mettre une
opposition anna cros gouvernement et
avoir une cohabitation donc c'est là
l'argument c'est de donner une
cohabitation à maquereau pour qu'ils ne
puissent pas avoir les pleins pouvoirs
et gérer la france tout seul après
laffaire thomas thévenoud et la
présidentielle où benoît hamon a dépassé
de peu les 5% sur ce territoire
pas facile de se présenter avec
l'étiquette parti socialiste avocate
âgée de 53 ans catherine diagne mis sur
sa personnalité pour convaincre
au delà de l'étiquette il ya des valeurs
et que ces valeurs là je pense que je
peux les transcender que et que c'est à
moi qu'il faut qu'ils fassent confiance
parce que je serai l'ambassadrice de ce
territoire et que je saurai les défendre
jean patrick courtois et bazana dire que
son favori pour être présent au second
tour pour qu'un troisième candidat les
rejoigne il faudrait une forte
participation en 2012 elle n'était que
de 50 9% dans cette circonscription et
on découvre ensemble les noms des huit
autres candidats ils sont quatorze au
total à briguer les suffrages des
électeurs ce dimanche dans cette
circonscription